Yle Areena.
Vessaan, ja viedähän, mitä niillä on mielestäkään.
Sitte vielako pisuario siinä näkyvällä paikalla?
Ei voi sen epähykienisempää olla.
Tähänki pitää saada ehdottomasti muutos.
Takaisin sellaiset vessat, naisille omat vessat, miehille omat vessat.
Tällainen mielipide avasi tämän kansanradion.
Kiitokset ensimmäiselle soittojalle.
Jälleen oika toivottaa perinteisteli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan.
Tämän puolituntisen aikana kuulem ajatuksia esimerkiksi liikenteestä, eläimistä ja turusta.
Tällä kertaa laivan ohjaimissa täällä mielipiteiden joella on Koiviston Lauri.
Erás kansalainen ehdottaa norppaa Suomen kansalliseläimeksi.
Toinen taasen ihmettelee, että eikö omassa pihassa saa nukkua rauhassa?
Ja onko villisijat Venäjän vakoojia?
Seppo täältä soittelee, ja su, oo jos Suomesta.
Ni täältä asti pitää käyvä kaks kertaa kuukausa naapurin miehen käyttämässä kaupassa kahta nelikymppistä naista.
Nä assuu vähän eri puolilla Helsinkiä.
Nä ei tohi mennä yksin kauppaan, ja kun ne o o o etätöissä, ne saa muuten.
Ja sit jos tarvii, että sinne konttorilla pitää käyvä, nii ne käy silloin firmasta hakemassa, ja tuovat takaisi kotia.
Yksinäisestä taista ei voi Helsingissä liikkua ollenkaan.
Kustosten jälkeen on aika sukeltaa liikenneteemoihin.
Aloitamme aiheen tekstillä, joka on lähetty Kansaradion verkkosivojen lomakkeella.
Palautta puheenvuoroon, jossa moittiin, kun sähköskuuteissa ei ole pirikelloa.
Vaikka skuuteissa tai kaikissa polkupyörissä sellainen olisi, ei tulisi tapahtumaan sitä, että kaikki kyseisellä välineellä liikkujat soittaisivat kelloa jokaisen jalankulkijan takalähestyessä, kumpa edes hiljentäisivät vauhtiaan.
Sen sijaan jalankulkijat voisivat ottaa vastuuta liikkumisestaan, ja katsoa taakseen ennen kuin kääntyvät tai siirtyvät sivusuunnassa.
Oma terveyshän on kuitenkin myös pelissä.
Itsekin jalankulkija, nimimerkki, oli tämän tekstin lähettänyt meille Kansaradion verkkosivojen lomakkeella.
Va olii, Lantti täällä. Ma pom pitäisi saada kulkea enemmän kuin neljä viis.
Mikä siinä on, kun ne on tien tukkoina suolla liikenteessä ja joutuu tuleen vaarallisia ohituksia. Siinä mu asia, se o hei.
Nyt on Suomeen tullut uusi muoti. Alkaa maantiet ja sillat pettämään.
Aas on vähän insinöörien koulutushukassa, ammattitaitohukassa, on jo tippunut parvekkeita, talon, seunustoja ja muita, nytten on uusi linnitys Suomessa.
Sillat ja maantiet, ojanpenkereet ja muut rikkovat kaiken. Hyvä päivänjatkoa.
Häätä ehdottaa, että kun joku ajaa takakonttiin kiini, niin laittaa hätävilkuut päälle, koska se on vaaran paikka.
Se varoittaa muuta liikennettä, huomauttaa takan ja tulijalle törkeästä ajota vasta. Hyvä jatkoa vaan, ei muuta.
Työtön, Toni, tässä tuusulasta tervehdys kaikille kansanradiokuuntelijoille.
Tässä vaan tulee ihmetystä mieleen, että kaikki nää asiat, mistä mä oon puhunut jo kymmenen vuotta sitten.
Elikä, kännykänne, käyttö, alaikäsille, energiajuomat alaikäsille, kurin pitämättömyys.
Kaikki nää alkaa nivoutuu yhtee.
Kaikki on varmaan jo huomannut tuo kaduilla ja tuntureilla, ettei oo mitää vanhoilla auktoriteettien kunnioituksella väli.
Eikä nii pois päi, nii sitä vaan sanon, että, nää ihmiset ketkä, niinku meikäläinen kiustii, ja en oo ainoa varmastikaa, mitkä on huomannut sen, että tällä nykymeiningillä ei tuu yhtää sitä sommasta, ku ei oo kuria, ei oo kasvokkaan kansakälmistä, ja, en mä muuta tästä sanokuvaa, et hyvää, jatkoa, kiitos, moi.
Sei, ja täältä syysmästä, terve.
Terve, terve.
Rouva, mikä?
Mikä, tai meiti, mikähän o?
Kä ilmoitte, et syysmässä on muka huono tiet, niin kyllä.
Muun mielestä paikattu tie on aivan hyvä.
Mun mielestä tää tiet oot kunnossa.
Va oon nyt muualta tullu sysmään.
Muutamia vuosia sitten, mä huomasin jo alun perin, et syysmässä on hirveen ystävällisiä ihmisiä.
Niitten kans voi jutella, milloin vaan, missä vaan, avataan tuo lenkipolulla tai missä tahans.
Jäädä juttelee.
Autoilijat yleensä, etten, mummoki kulkee, kuljen nyt Rollan kanssa, ja autoilijat on hirveen kohtelija, kiitos heille.
Olen sitten sähtynyt sinne istuskelemaan ja katselemaan ihmisiä, autoilijat, niin kyllä ne on kohtelijaita kaikille, eikä vaan Rollattori mummoille, tämmöstä asiaa.
Pisteet siis syysmäläisille?
Pisteet syysmäläisille, kyllä joo, ihan, ihan kaikkialle. Hyvä, kesäjatkoa sulle.
Sitä samaa, kiitoksia, hei hei.
Kiitos, hei.
Kyllä on nyt käyty keskustelua sysmän liikenteestä, se tunnetaan sahdin lisäksi nyt siis teistäkin.
Me jatkamme kuitenkin matkaa sysmästä eteenpäin, kun korviimme saapuu polttavia aiheita.
Metsätalouden asiantuntijana voin antaa semmosen pätevän lausunnon, että eteläeurooppalaiset, espanialaiset, italialaiset, portugalilaiset, ranskalaiset, on nii laiskaa porukkaa, ei muuta ku sitä viiniä lipittää ja nuota nii patonkia, mussuttaa, että ne ei oo pihoja ja mehtiä haravoineet, ni sen takia syttyy pienestäkin kipinestä metsäpaloa, että menkää haravoimaan ne pihat, kaikki eteläeurooppalaiset, mussuttajat, menkää sinne haravoimaa.
Joo.
Joo, tätä pohjalmata terve.
Mä ihmettelin, täskö tuota kuunteli tota pelastoryymää, ommaa ku palovaitosta, et tämmöset niinku mehtapalovartani.
Eikö tämmöinen asia, tu oi itsestää ollu jo estää selvä asia, että?
Telikö, perkäsit, pahäsit, pahäsit, kaitis, tanoo, vai?
Ja sit, ette, tanoo, ne, jos ei paikka kunnoi, saa tulla et porukkaa, mutta, mille se hyvä rasi porukkasen kasa, joka sen lähtee sammuttamastuipalaa, et se ihmetyttää, et se ihmetyttää, et.
Tääntä, koei saa, ilmeisesti osalistuu, et se on tarkkaa hommaa, sikii, et, saako osalistuu, miket tämmöset, et se väitäs ihmetyttää.
Tosiaan kuunteli tässä voa, et, jos laitää ajoinovela liniautoa viemää sammutuskalustoa tonne, et tää porukkaa tonne pohjoisiin, ta, emisin palaadi.
Se aikistää multa tunti.Keliko, täytyy kaitista helpoa. Sillähän ne puolusvoimati liikkuu. Et viedää ryhmä rämää, sinne, minkä tarkoitetaan.
Tei, mitää, kiitoksia, ja paivaisteko, hei.
Joh, tuuri, siis tulee taastuta, et on niin kaujaisti noita maastopaloja ja tulipaloja joka paikassa, ja sittes viranavaiset sanoi, ette, epäväinen turtahalansydyt.
Toisaalla puhutaan taas tästä hybridisonasta, ja sitä eihän sen parempaa hybridiasetta ole, kun tää tuli.
Sitä ei kukaan tiedä koskaan. Kuka on sytyttänyt, ja onko se salama, tai onks se, mikä se on?
Kyl nyt tarvitsi ihmisten olla tarkkaa, ja katsella, kuka touhuaa, missäki, ja miten.
Niin, kyllä saadaa olla kiitollisia, että ei täällä oo semmasia. Niin, että, miettikääpä vähän. Heippa.
No, ma, täällä moikka, hoit.
Moi, moi.
Semmoisella asialla kävin pitkästä aikaa oman isän haudallaan, mennyt muutama vuosi välistä, mutta nyt kun kävin, niin ihmetyttää se, että miksi ihmiset vie toisten ihmisten haudolta lyhtytelineen.
Eli, siellä, sinun isäsi haudolla oli lyhtyteline, ja nyt se oli hävinnyt.
Siellä on ollut ensin alun perin yks lyhtyteline, ja se hävis muutama vuosi sitten, jälkeisen ne on hankittu kaks kuuta, ja nyt ei ollut enää kumpaa.
Ja se on nyt juuri näiden pari vuoden aikana sitten, jonnekin.
Nyt pari vuoden aikana ne on hävinny, ne molemmat lyhtytelineet, niissä oli myös lyhytty.
Nä oli ihan tiipit, samata, niinku ihan sinne sopivat, ihan asialliset lyhtytelineet, lyhtyjen kerran, mut kumpaakaan ei enää ollut.
Jotenki tuntua, että nyt tästä asiasta en lähtis valttamatta, ku monesti syytetään nuorisoa, niin ehkä nyt hautausmaalla, kuitenki se keski-ikä saastaa työriää vähän siellä nuorisoijää, hieman yläpuolella, niin sanoisin, että kaiken ikäisille sellaisia terveisiä, että ei ne niinkalliitaa ne lyhtyteliseet, ettei kuvasi omaa ostaa.
Nyt oli kyseessä nimenomaan juuri teidän oma lyhtyteline, ettei ollut mikään niinku seurakunnalta lainattu, tai.
Ja, nyt oli ihan oma.
Ja, harmillista.
No, kyllä, Niina.
Kiitoksia, kun soitit kansaradioja kerroittamaan.
Kiitos, mukavaa päivä jää.
Sitä samaa.
Näistä tulisista aatoksista siirrymme eläinosioon.
Enen puheluita yksi WhatsApp-viesti: "Terve, haluaisin oikaistaa monen väärän käsityksen ratsastuksesta, jonka mukaan ratsastus ei olisi urheilua. Kyseessä on tasapainoa, lihaksia ja kuntoa vaativa urheilulaji. Ja jos ette usko, niin käykääpä vaikka itse kokeilemassa."
Näin meille kirjoitti nimi merkki "Heppa, tyttö", WhatsApp-viestissä. Meille kansaradioon voi lähettää WhatsApp-viestejä sekä tällaisia tekstikommentteja, että myös äänimuotoisia, jollaisia niitäkin on muutama mukana tässä ohjelmassa.
Kansaradioon WhatsApp-numero on 044551544.
Tervehdys kaikille. Se vaan surettaa, kun joka kesä saa lukea leedistä, että kuutti on kuullut katiskaa. Meillä on näin hieno ja aynutlaatuinen eläinkokoa maailmassa, ja silti Saimaa Norpan kohtalo on näin huono.
No, mitä se kertoo meistä suomalaisista? Me vihataan luontoa, ja meillähän on oikeus tulla ensimmäisenä, viis siitä, vaikka kuuttaja kuolee.
Nyt ihan oikeasti tarvittaisiin asennemuutosta, ja siksi ehdotan, että Saimalle tulisi katiskakielto.
Tiedän, että on norppaturvallisia katiskoja, mutta minun mielestä pitäisi olla ehdoton katiskakielto.
Ja jos me saisimme katiskakielon, niin viiden vuoden päästä me kiiteltäisiin, että tämä tuli tehtyä.
Samalla olisi hyvä nostattaa Saimaa Norppa Suomen kansalliseläimeksi, jolloin arvostus nousisi.
Aikoinaanahan, Yrjo Kokko, sai asennemuutoksien kautta vaulujoutsenen pelastettua sukupuuttoon kuolimiselta, ja arvostus nousi joutsentakohtaan.
Joten, Saimaa Norppa Suomen kansalliseläimeksi ja katiskakielto Saimaalle. Kiitos.
Totuoma, täällä päivää. Tuli eläinsuojelulaki, että Aaseja ei saa pitää yksin eläjinä, ja varmaa hyvä laki.
Mutta ilmeisesti, niinku minäkin, oon olempi arvoisempi, koska minä saan edellä kyllä yksin.
Mulle ei määrätä sitä kaveria, ja sitten Aaseista on kolma kauheesti pulaa, että pitäis saada kaveria näille Aaseille.
Ni minä olis yks vinkki, että tuolta eduskunnasta niitä löytäis, ja sit hallituksesta varsinkin, siellä olis kyllä Aasia, ihan sieh hommaan, ihan joutavia.
Ei tässä samolta, moro.
Hei, nyt synty epäily, eikä ne villisijät idästä ole venäläisiä vakoilijoita Naamio puvuissa.
Eduskunta on istuntotauolla, mutta kyllä kansalaisella riittää siitä huolimatta terveisiä päättäjille.
Elä häkeläi nyt täällä. Kuule, Orpo, sä tekisit suurel pahaleluksenko, sä jättäisit koko politiikan, ku et säisit mitään ymmelä.
Sä puhut, puhuta heitä. Et jätää nuariville, ei sun kannata, terve.
Salokaupongin mettakulman jätkövää hyvää päivää koko kansan radiolla läpi Suomen.
Olisi korkea aikaviidakin suomalaisten otteja katsoa, miten me olemme saaneet tässä Suomessa aikaa siitä, ku liitymään Eurooppa-uunionen jäsenmaa.
Tämä hallituksen ja pääministerin toiminta on kuvaista jo yksinelmaa sitä, että asiat on menossa paaisten väärintää, kuinka se sitten maksaa, ni se on veronmaksaja.
Presidenti Stupin toimet ja teot ja poheet alkavat näkkoä maailmankuvalista Kasperinuken toulta, joka ei katso sitä, että Suomi ei ole mikään pieni maa, ja se tarvitsee tukea.
Olemme kohta samalla tiellä kuin Ukraina itse.
Ve luuletteko, että meitä tuetaan tai tulla auttaa samalla tavalla?
Ukraine ja Venäjän sota on todella lopetettavissa, ja se on järkeä lopettaa, koska tällä me olemme liitymäsien pikkuiljaa mukaan.
Se ei kysy sitten, mikä on meidän velvoite, koska me olemme osallistaa avustaneet sotaa käyvää maata toiseen.
Miksi tämä puolue, tai nykyiset henkilöt, tai nykyinen nuori väestö ottaa ymmärtääkseen, että yhteiskuntarakentimme on täysin ala-arvoisessa tasossa, ja meillä on kerjuu edessä.
Se ei katso syntymää, tai varallisuutta, vaan se koittelee kaikkea, ku se päivä tulee.
Se ei kätkää tyymyydestä, alkaa tekee ihmisistä ihmisiä, koska syntymää kuolemaa ja sairoida kulkee käsi kädessä, halusitte tai ette tervee.
Hah, kuinkas sitten kävikään? Ministerit saivat VIP-paikat ralleihin.
Tä heistä sitä pietään kyllä huolta, ettei heidän maan tarpe omaa rahaa pussiaa aukasta, ja kaikkiin muihinkin paikkoihin niillä on vapaa pääsy,
että sen ku menevät vaan, että näin ja se on, että nämä ministerit on nii vahaa osaisia, että pitää sitä niistäki huolta pitää.
On tämä Suomen maa kyllä semmoinen maa, että ei tätä enää oikeusvaltioksi voi kyllä todeta.
No nii, täältä soittelee armi ilomantsista, ja semmoisella asialla mä tänne nyt kansanradioon asti lähdin, että nuo herkun hinnat ovat aivan käsittämättömät.
Ei, ei tämmöisen eläkeläisen palkat niihin riitä, kun lapsen lapset kyselee vaan.
Ässä, keksit, niitä ne aina pyyttelee, ja ei, ei niitä enää tässä taloudessa ostella.
Kyllä hallitus, ottakas tästä nyt vähän koppia, ja hoitakaa herkkujen hinnat alas. Kiitos.
Herkkujen jälkeen on vuorossa kommentteja aiempien ohjelmien mielipiteisiin.
Kansanradion viime jaksoissa on puhuttu jukurtipurkkien loppuun asti tyhjentämisestä ja sen jatkokäytöstä.
Yksi kansalainen ehdotti, että tällaista litran purkista voisi askarrella linnun pöntön.
Tähän aiheeseen tuli Whatsappiin viesti, jossa lukee näin:
Pöntöön tehty pahvinen tyhjä tölkki ei sovi linnun pöntöksi.
Tällä tavoin luki Whatsapp viestissä, jonka meillä oli lähettäneet Tarja ja Veikko Lahdesta.
He vetosivat pöytolais Suomeen, niin tarkistin asian sieltä.
Järjestöstä vastattiin, että hauskan näköinen viritys, mutta tuolainen pönttö on turhan ahdas ja helposti ryövättävissä, ei tuollaista.
Näin siis kommentoitiin pöytolais Suomesta kuvaa, jossa oli linnun pönttö, joka oli tehty tyhjään litran maitopurkkiin.
No hei, tää on Terttu täältä Juvalta.
Hei hei.
Kuuntelin teidän ohjelmaa, ja siinä eräs nainen kertoi tästä lääkkeen sivuvaikutuksesta.
Mitästä kolesterolääkkeen?
Niii, ja mulla on kokemusta tästä kyllä Aitolaila kanssa.
Täällä on semmoinen selytyspaperi, nii ne kannattaa hirveen tarkkaa lukea.
Siiis siellä on ihan mahoottomia juttuja, lihasten hajoamisesta, ja kaikkii maksai, ja tämmösiin häiriöihin.
Ja ottaa yhteys, siellä sitten sanotaan, että kannattaa ottaa heti yhteys lääkärin, että voi olla, että ne vaikutukset ei sitten mahdollisesti häviäkään, mitä niistä kovia vaikutuksia tulee, että hirveen tärkeetä olisi ihmisten lukea.
Tämä oikein tarkkaa, tämä paperi.
Nää lopetin kolesteroliläkkeen käytön, ku tuli nii hirvoittavat säryt jalkoihin, että ei kersinyt enää.
Kiitoksia tästä puhelosta, ja oikea hyvää sanotaanjatkoa.
Kiitos, sama, kiitos hyvästä ohjelmasta.
Kiitos.
Täällä herra, eli vapaa herra Helsingistä. Minä kiitän kaikkia kansanradioon osallistuneita rohkeudesta ja aloitteelisuudesta.
Ongelman nimääminen on ensimmäinen askel oman toimijuuden ottamisessa.
Mutta miksi jättää asia siihen?
Edellisessä jaksossa kehotettiin liittymään poliittiseen puolueeseen.
Mikä onkin mainiokeino viimesijaisen päämäärän saavuttamiseksi, oli se sitten oman palkkionsan nostaminen, tai jokin jalomielisempi sellainen.
Suomi on demokraattinen kansalaisyhteiskunta, ottakaamme toimijuus omin käsimme.
Jos ei liittymään puolueeseen, niin liity yhdistykseen tai perusta sellainen.
Verkostoidu, järjestä tapahtuma, järjestä mielenosoitus ja flyereita kylillä, mistä tahansa aiheesta, myös vaalien välillä.
Järjestä rahonkeräys, muista, että tässä maassa kukaan ei kielä tekemästä näitä asioista.
Ole se muutos, jonka haluat nähdä.
Toimijuuden lisääminen vähentää ahdistusta.
Tähän ohjelmaan soittaminen oli hieno ensiaskel, nyt ota seuraava.
Ehtä olemme jo kaikki ottaneet oman me, ihan vaan kuuntelemalla tämän viestin ja tätä arvokasta lähetystä. Kiitos.
Niin, kuuntelija täällä, ei se Marian poimija, tai mikään semmoinen helppo homma ole,
että ne työttömät, jotka ovat työttömiä, niin voisi mennä marjoja poimii.
Ensinäkin täytyy osata liikkua metsässä, tuntee marjat, ja osata noukia.
Se ei kaikilla käy. Täytyy olla jollain lailla tutustunut Suomen luontoon.
Ja ei oo mikään hanttihomma, että ei sinne ketä vaan voi pistää marjon noukintaa.
Eikä sienistää, tietenkää. Siinä on vielä vaikeampaa, ku täytyy tunnistaa sienet.
En tiedä, mistä ne asialaiset on oppinut. Sillä tavalla liikkuu Suomen metsissä ja noukkimaan niitä marjoja, mutta suomalaiset, nuoret ja vanhemmat ei oikein siihen sovikaan, kun se on vaikea liikkua ensinnäkin, ja sitten täytyy olla semmoinen halunoukia, että se ei kyllä kaikilta onnistu. Kiitos.
Tässä ohjelmassa on kohta vuorossa turku osio, koska, miksipä ei?
Sitä pakettia ennen vielä yksi kirje aivan toista aiheesta, siinä on kirjoittu tällä tavoin.
Kansaradion kuuntelijät, mummoni ehdotti minulle, että kirjoitan tänne huoleni ja pyyntöni.
Olen erityiserkkä nuori, minun pahin yliherkkyys on tupakan savu. Kohta koulut taas alkavat, ja joudun liikkumaan julkisilla paikoilla enemmän. Tämä tarkoittaa sitä, että joudun kaikin keinoin välttämään epämiellyttävää tupakan savua.
Sitä on jalkakäytävillä, kaupan ovien edessä, bussipysäkeillä ja kaikkialla, missä tupakoidaan. Uimarannatkin jouduin kiertämään kaukaa, koska niissäkin poltettiin tupakkaa.
Tupakan savu aiheuttaa minulle päänsärkyä silmien kirvelyä ja astmaattisia yskän kohtauksia.
Pyydän ystävällisesti ja kauniisti tupakan polttajia huomioimaan kanssakulkijat ympäristössä, missä me kuljemme yhdessä.
Tällä tavoin luki kirjeessä, jonka meillä oli lähettä nyymerkki "Raikas ilma kaikille ja tupakan tumpit roskiin bliis".
Kansanradion voi lähettää kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postia osoitteeseen, Kansanradio PL 79 00 00 24 Yleisradio.
Joo, morjesta, ajatteli ottaa esille Turu yliopiston avomen opinnot, museologian opinnot, jotka olivat tosi mielenkiintoisia.
Mei oli viis jaksoa siinä ja kolme kolmosta, ja sitten sain kaks nelosta, ja mulle jäi just kolven plikku neljä keskiarvoksetta.
En saanut nelosta tietenkää, ku ei ollut sitä kolmea, nelosta ja kahta kolmosta.
Aattelee niin, että jonkunlaista psykologista silmää ois ollut näillä opettajilla, mutta koko alusta asti vaikutti siltä, että he aattelivat omaa itseään vaan, eikä meitä opiskelijoita.
Vastauksena tuli vain kuittailu, että heillä on oma tutkimustyö, niin mä monesti oon ajatellut sitä, että ku on opiskelijoita, jotka haluaa korottaa,
esimerkiksi lukiossa, tai jossakin yleensä parantaa arvosanaa, niin ei tämä nyt kauhean kannustavalta vaikuttanut.
Mä annoin tämmöistä kritiikkiä jo ihan opiskeluaikanakin, näin, mutta näköjään tulin sitten koruttamasti esille.
Ymmäsin, että olin ainoa, joka ois halunnut koruttaa dokumentaatiokurssia, näin, mutta ei niinkielaista vastaantulemista ollenkaa.
Jos nyt pari sivua tekstiä pitää lukea ja arvioida, että onko se velo se arvoinen, näin, niin mun mielestä pitäis pystyä tämmöisen tekemään, näin, ei voi selittää vaan, että ei ole aikaa, että keskittyy tutkimustyöhön, näin.
Koista, tää on kauhean itsekeskeistä, ja tää itsekeskeisyys tuli hyvi esille, koko niinku aikana, näin, että.
Kaattelivat omaa ittiään, näin, ja.
Oi semmoista teeskentelyä, että ei ole hienoja, mielenkiintoisia töitä, näin, ja olen todellakin pettynyt siihen, että, et ei annettu edes korotusmahollisuutta, näin, niipä.
Minulle jäi sitten arvosanaks kolme, näin, ja.
Olti esitellen opintosuorituksia, näin, ni.
Kyn mä vähän niinku oon pettynyt tähän Turu yliopistoa, voimeyliopiston hommaan, näin, että.
Kyllä oon maksanutkaa, koska ohjaus oli mun mielestä puhutteelista, näin, ja.
En ymmärrä tällaista ollenkaa, että, jotain miltä mä oon, hei.
Hei vaan kaikille kansararialaisille, haluan kiittää välillä, kun yleensä on, vain sitä toista asiaa.
Kympi näille kaupunkinsairaalan silmäpoliklinikalle oleville, työntekijöille kaikille, olitte ihania.
Kiitos, hei.
No, laritas, turvista, morjes.
Morjes, morjes.
Tämmönen pikku asia, et, miksei saa nukkuu omaa pihaa silleet, ni ku rauhassa. Tule poliisit herättämään.
Eli nukuit omassa pihassa, ja sitten poliisit tuli herättämään.
Kyllä, siellä on heliä poliisia, joku naavo oli soittamassa.
Millä tavoin nukuit?
Siis nukuin.
Ni, ni, mut sin, missä, tuolissa, teltassa?
Ei, nukuita sanoin, tyykkitellenä alla.
Joo.
Puhainen kännis.
Ja siitä tulti, ja sitten poliitit tuli hakemaa.
Joo, joo.
Ihan rauhassa nukuit.
Jos, mä nukkunen, mä, mitä riehukkaa?
No, olitko sitä ennen tehnyt jotakin sellaista, joka nii ko...
Ei, ei ollut yhtään, nii, aivan hiljaa ollut.
Eli, omalla pihalla ei saa enää nukkua rauhassa.
Ei, näköjää.
Kiitoksia tästä tiedosta.
Onni, mut tää on tämmöstä poliisivalimilla, näkö, resursseja hakee nukkuvaa pojesea.
Saitko jatkaa, jos sain sitten unia vielä?
Ei, no, Roo voi tulla hakee mut pois sitten.
Joo.
Silvä Yttö, kiitoksia tästä, ja sinne Turkuun oikea hyvää päiväjatkoa.
Ja kiitoksia kansanradista.
Ei.
Seuraavassa puheluduossa saamme todistaa kahta asiaa.
Ensinnäkin perheen sisäinen keskustelu saa vähän enemmän kuuluvuutta,
ja toiseksi toimittajan aluksi aika pihalla, mistä puhutaan.
Tätä ennen kerron vielä kansanradion puhelinnumeron, ettei ainakaan jää kertomatta.
Se on nolla, kahdeksan, nolla, nolla, yksi, viisi, neljä, kuusi, neljä.
Ja puhelu on soittajalle maksuton.
Ja muistuksena, että sunnuntaisin kello kaksitoista kolmekymmentä alkaen,
tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmis vastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Päivää.
Päivää, päivää.
Eino täällä soittaa.
Sytä, mietin, että, mis nykyään käytetään sähkötestereitä?
Et, mis nyt, äijätetään vaikka heinänkarttia laitaan siihen aitaan?
Anteeks, mitä käytetään sähkötestereitä?
Ni, et se laitaan siihen aidan päälle, ja sit se alkaa piippaamaan, jos siellä on sähköä.
Tällä ei kunnen kuin vaikka lehmäaidessaan, on se sähkö siinä, niinkö?
Ja.
Ja, ja tää on nyt joku uus, uus tällainen testeri.
No, on näitä hetkeä käytetty, mut mä aloin miettii sitä vasta tässä.
Ja?
Telään.
Ja, sinun mielestä se sitä ei pitäisi käyttää sellaista vai?
Ei.
Miksi ei?
No, koska se on paljon hauskempaa ottaa toi sähköisku.
Niin, niin, aivan. Oletko sinä saanut sähköiskua siitä aidesta?
No, olen, monta kertaa olen testannut.
Et kerrasta oppinut.
No, en oo vieläkään oppinut.
Selvä, kiitoksia tästä puolesta, ja oikein hyvää sunnuntajatkoa.
Jo, aippa.
Kerttu?
Terve, terve.
No, mun mielestä on kyllä kumma, että niitä, ku mun pikkuveli soitti äsken, nii, se valitti niistä sähkötestereistä.
Mun mielestä ois kyllä hyvää, että niitä käytettäs.
Ei tarvii ihmisten tulla ja testailla ite, ku oon sellainen keksitty.
Minkälainen tää on siis, tää ihan niinku käytännössä, tää, äsken ku.
En mä tiin, mitä se toimii, mut jo otenki sillä, et se kertoo, et tää onko sähköaidossa sähkö.
Onko ne joku semmonen kännykän kokoinen, vai?
Ei, pienempi.
Pienempi, laitee sitten, sitä vaan jotakin testataa.
Ja, ja sinun mielestä se on oikein hyvä.
Ja.
Selvä juttu, kiitoksia ja oikein hyvää sunnuta jatkoa.
Kiitos, Heppa.
Siinä oli sähköstä kyse.
Näinpä onkin luontevaa siirtyä sähköisiä tiedotusvälineitä koskeviin kannanottoihin.
Tätä ennen juhlallista asiaa.
Yleisradio täyttää syyskuussa sata vuotta.
Yle Uutiset suunnittelee juhlan kunniaksi verkkoartikkelia kansanradion osallistuvista suomalaisista.
Mikäli tähän juttuun voisi kuvata ja haastatella juuri sinua,
niin laita yhteystietosi kansanradion tuttuun sähköpostiosoitteeseen.
Se on kansan.radio@yle.fi.
Lähetät tuo viesti 15. elokuuta mennessä.
Yhteystietosi uutistoimitukseen.
Kirjoita sähköpostin otsikkokenttään vielä sanat:
Yle.Sata.
Aina, mummuse täällä taas katsoitteko torstaina elämäni biisiä?
Onko parempaa ohjelmaa oltu ykkösellä näkemässä?
Hienoa, kiitos.
No heippa, olen urheiluista ystävää hyvin paljoja.
Iimesunnointena tuli TV2. yleisurheilua, Kalelan kisaatte.
Kylläpä oli mielenkiinto ja hyvää katsottava.
Ko oli sateinen päivä, nii ei yhtä halmittata täyti olla sisällä.
Oli niin ääryttömän hyvää ohjelma koko aikaa,
ja ihana katsella semmosia nuoria, terveitä ja urheilullisia naisia ja miehiä.
Aivan mielyttävä ohjelma, tämmösiä mielellään katso.
Ja toivon, että suomalais urheilijat pärjää muutenki, muuallakin kuin Kaleivan kisaissa.
Ja toivon, että suomalaiset rupes enemmän kannustamaan suomalaisia urheilijoita.
Se on niin äärettömän hienoa, kauniita ihmisiä.
Hytää, heippaan.
Nimi merki rock, haluan vaadia semmoista asiaa.
Ja ottaa huomioon vähän ralaiset, myösketko.
Vaikelee aivan pohia ei varaa, nii.
Voisko Vossappi jättää pois?
Voisko soittaa, haluaa radioa?
Ja se, et oo aina asia.
Valkaa, haluaa liikennet tätä paikkoa radiosuomassa?
Ei, se oli siis, liikennet tätä vähän liikaa.
Ei, me olis siis tää enääkin muualla.
Sitä vaan soittelin, että kun kuuntelee Yle Radio Suomee,
niin kiitokset asiallisista ja mukavista toimittajista.
Muilla kanavilla usein on semmosia tyhjännauravia,
omia juttujaan ja vitsejään kertovia,
että ei niitä kestä kuunnella.
Hyvää kesää Ylen toimittajille.
Hei.
No, Anttiki iski tässä terve.
Terve, terve.
Halusin välittää tämmöset terveiset,
ku ollaan tässä nyt kaverin kanssa.
Pari päivää roudattu,
autolla tavaraa edespaikasiaa laittu,
Kylä Suomi, arminaisesti soimaan,
yleensä kuenlaattosta,
omasta matkapuhelimasta,
suoratoista palvelon kautta musiikkia,
mutta annet anotus Yle Suomelle,
ja halusin välittää terveiset,
että ootta saanut nyt kaksi uutta,
23-vuotiasta, fania ja vakio kuutelijaa,
tämmöset terveiset,
sillä mekin silmäisesti
täällä ohjelma on kohdenettavaa
vanemmalle sukupolvelle,
mutta kyllä meitäkin täällä edelleen
nöytyy, jotka edustaa
vähän nuorempaa sukupolvea,
tai siellä lukeuduu,
kuinka vähän nuorisoa,
mutta mekin tätä radiota edellemme,
mielellämme kuuntelemme,
ja tämä on kyllä ollut erinomainen show,
mikä täällä täällä on.
Hienoa kuulla tämä,
mikä erityisesti on tehnyt
tämän mielyttävän kuuntelukokemuksen,
mistä olet erityisesti tykänneet?
No, erityisesti annetaan kunnianvaininta
näille kappaleille,
jotka on,
täälle kotimaiselle kappaleille,
joilta ei oo aikataan tuutu vastaan,
ja perinteisiä nimenomaan,
että tulee suunaltua kyllä kotimaista musiikkia,
mutta arvemmin tulee näitä
perinteisiä kappaleita kuunaltua,
ja niitä oo kyllä ilo kuunnella.
Hienoa, kiitoksia,
paljon tästä puhelusta,
ja oikein hyvää kesäpäivätkoa teillä.
Kiitoksia, sitä samaa.
Hei hei.
Syrkkamäksellä täällä.
Ihmettelin, eikö tänään tule kansanradio?
Onko se vaan rallit,
mikä ryöstää kansanradionkin meitä pois?
Kiitos.
Kohta suunnataan Maunon seurassa rannalle.
Sitä ennen muistutan,
että kansanradion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan
joka perjantai kello 21.
Oli ralleja, tai ei.
Jos merkkaat sydämen kuvasta ja tilaat ohjelmasta
ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta,
niin saat aina ensimmäinen tiedon,
kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
No niin, Mauno Voutilainen,
täältä Jyväskylästä ja Kelan eläkkeellä,
ja tervetuloa kansanradio,
ja hiekka ranta kesäinen helteellä,
kirkkaan väriset pekinit piristää rantaa,
ja vesi on lämpintä uido,
vaikka kilometri kerrallaan,
ja sitten työn välitykseen.
Kiitos.
Vielä on ainakin ruokatutkijoista asiaa luvassa.
Ennen viimeisiä puheluita,
minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää,
koiviston Lauri kiittää ja kumartaa,
kansanradio jälleen viikon päästä.
Koskahan tähän maailmaan saadaan
oikeudenmukaisuus ja tasa-arvo ja rehellisyys.
En ymmärrä näitä ruuantutkijoita esimerkiksi.
Tänään tämä ruoka on hyvää, huomenna se on huonoa.
Näitä tulee melkein päivittäin.
Mihin täällä voi enää luottaa?
No, iletaas tässä hei,
tikapuita taivaaseen,
kappalesta tuli mieleen,
tämmönen ku kädet liian,
heikot jalat, ei kanna,
eikö sinne ole hissiä, tä?
Hoh, hellettä, sanoi Jänis Pakkasella.